joining us right now is a world series
champion once again kind enough to call
into this show frequently after big time
playoff games in which he's homered we
always appreciate when he calls in a big
game tonight certainly for the san diego
padres as the dodgers who are just a
mere two and a half games behind the
san francisco giants in the nl west
taking on the padres tonight the red hot
dodgers in san diego along with justin
turner back here on the show how are you
doing justin
i'm good rach how are you i'm doing no
always uh and uh you're you're here
courtesy of fresh and lean which we'll
talk about with you uh and the mule
delivery service uh in a moment um walk
me through the the red hot streak that
obviously you're coming off of a loss
but uh winning 9 out of 10 is something
you'll sign for any day of the week
where where did this start did it start
with the trade deadline deal walk me
through what you got justin
yeah i think the trade deadline was a
crucial part of it obviously adding um
you know danny duffy and then
uh the big trade with scherzer and and
trey turner coming over to just
enormous impact pieces and what they've
been able to contribute already
uh is off the charts and
um you know just like every other team
in the league i think we've been
dealing with a lot of injuries and a lot
of guys on spending time on il and
trying to piece it back together as
those guys are coming off and
we still haven't had our entire lineup
out there except for maybe one game um
but we're hoping to get rookie back in
the series
down here in san diego and and have the
whole lineup together and i think uh
you know the the sky's the limit when
when you get all those guys in there uh
just crazy to think about you know trade
turner mookie beth max muncie corey
seeger
and the list goes on and on and on down
the line up
they're just all tough outs and and such
dynamic players both you know in the box
defensively and on the bases well i mean
you live in the clubhouse um team plane
dugout batter's box side of things i
live on the microphone couch remote
control uh long time listener first time
caller side of things and on my side of
things people look at your lineup in the
payroll and say of course this is what
they should be doing um but in the
reality though um as you mentioned
injuries and um
being defending world champs um
making a trade like that what what type
of jolt does that send through a locker
room knowing that the aggressivity that
you like to bring that your manager
wants you to bring is matched by
somebody in the upstairs who's like
screw it let's just do this and let's
get two big time players i understand
what danny duffy brings but
that trade from the the nationals what
does that send to the locker room to
your clubhouse
yeah it just
confirms that you know the actions are
are matching the words right i think our
ownership group talks every year uh in
spring training as well as our front
office about
the commitment to winning a championship
and um when you see them you're in and
you're out go out at the deadline and
bring in impact pieces that
you know they feel
will help us accomplish our ultimate
goal of winning world series
uh then you just appreciate the the
follow through and and you know not just
blowing a bunch of hot air at us telling
us that they want to win but not doing
anything about it they're actually
you know going out there and you know
the owners are signing up on the trades
that the front office and andrew freeman
are you know
grinding and working on for
weeks
at a time and and
you know sometimes the owners don't sign
off on those trades so
uh you know it's a collective tip of the
hat for the front office and the
ownership group for
you know putting us in a position to to
compete for a championship and now it's
our turn to do our part and
do you uh just in the mold of being a
lead pipe wielding professional trying
to get better uh justin turner do you
seek out scherzer at any point and say
what do you see when you were facing me
like about your approach to hitting
based on his approach to trying to get
you out do do you have conversations
like that or or no
i haven't had that conversation with him
yet but i have had conversations in the
past with some of our pitchers and one
of the most impactful ones on my career
with the conversation i have with zach
grinky uh about five or six years ago
about how he would pitch me and
um you know that's the reason i stand so
close to the plate because he went in
and did a deep dive on me and
uh was telling me how awful i am hitting
the ball on the outside part of the
plate and i asked him i said so you
think i should stand on top of the plate
with the ball closer he goes i would get
as close to play as you possibly can
and so ever since that conversation i've
been on top of the plate and i've had
you know pretty good success swinging
the bat and also a lot of success
getting hit by pitches i'm sure
so
uh why haven't you had that conversation
with scherzer yet or is there something
you don't want to know or or what what
do you what or you just haven't had that
opportunity with max just no i just i
haven't had that opportunity haven't
really like shot it out i'm sure
there'll be a day that it comes out
naturally when we start talking about it
i know
he's one of the guys that i enjoy facing
most i think between him and johnny
cueto
uh are two guys that
i just really enjoy the compete part of
it because
uh obviously respect the hell out of
them and
i think the battles uh over the years
have been pretty good
um with
you know success on both sides so
i do respect the hell out of max and and
i love those that bats that
you know we had against each other but
i'm sure it'll come up at some point
like hey what do you got like
how do you get me out and uh you know
he's already jabbed me a couple times
like hey just pretend i'm pitching and
you'll probably hit a homer so
um
yeah maybe that's why i haven't asked
him yet or or is that just your nice way
justin turner of saying back when you
had that conversation with grenky you
were justin turner and now you're justin
friggin turner is that was that your
nice way of saying something like that
to me just maybe you know maybe maybe
there's definitely days where i feel
like justin freaking turner and there's
definitely days where i just feel like
playing all boring doesn't turn around
so that's baseball that's baseball now
that is baseball that is baseball in a
nutshell justin turner here on the rich
eisen show and one of the most
incredible stories of the entire
baseball season is the acquisition by
your team of albert pujols and watching
him work and rake against lefties for
sure
what has that been like for you the the
appearance of pujols in your clubhouse
and and having him around justin turner
yeah it's been it's been awesome um i
was lucky enough to to get to know
albert over the last four or five years
through our foundations and and teaming
up and
uh supporting their events and him
coming out and supporting some of our
events but then
uh so you know he's a great guy off the
field but getting to know him in the
clubhouse and getting to see him go
about his work every day you know he's
one of the first guys in the field every
single day at home or on the road
he's in the cage all the time working
just hearing his
positive reinforcement all the time with
all the guys and younger guys and
um you know he's in a role that he's not
used to being in he's used to playing
every day and getting his at-bat and he
came over here and was asked to
be okay with the reduced roll and and
play against lefties and pinch hit um
you know late in games and
he's embraced it and he's been
one of the best teammates i've i've ever
had uh just
unbelievable how much fun he has how
much he and still enjoys the game and
you can see it when when a guy hits a
homer when he's standing at the end of
the dugout with that huge smile waiting
to just give you the biggest bear hugs
yes sir
it's about to say
how hard he uh
he squeezes you in that hug he seems
like he likes warm hugs like you know
olaf the snowman from frozen it seems
like he does like the warm hugs justin
he loves the warm hugs yeah maybe i'll
start calling him olaf you know what
please you know go for it you you give
me credit don't i don't need it or i'll
take it either one that's fine with me
okay um so um just now that we're we're
at this part of the season i've got
justin turner of the los angeles dodgers
uh here on the rich eisen show um
the fact that you are now right back in
this mix right now um do you feel that
your team is best positioned because of
your experience the deep roster and the
the just the general sense of been there
done that you've got the ring and that
they're coming for your crown do you
have that sensibility
justin uh we do like where we're at we
think we're in a great position we think
we're right in
within reach
and
as you said the experience that we had
not only you know from the guys from the
team last year but even the two guys did
you know we brought in in um all three
guys really duffy and shers and and trey
turner have all won a world series as
well so they all know what it's about
and um you know we like where we're at
we think we're playing really good
baseball right now and
it should be a really fun and exciting
september
uh last one for you before we turn to
your your fresh and lean uh what you're
calling in also to talk about here on
the rich eisen show is the spider tax
stuff done is it over
is is the the sort of tsa checkpoints at
the at the baselines that we're seeing
uh on a nightly basis now for a couple
of months although it does seem to be
just just umpires now just want to touch
the glove and the hat and hand it right
back to guys but is this um
are we through this now in baseball or
something still up what can you walk me
through from your perspective
yeah
i mean i would love to say yes but i
think that you know baseball is a game
where
everyone's trying to constantly find an
edge and an advantage and i don't think
i don't know
i think right now it is out i don't
think guys are using it although you
know there's some nights when you see a
guy we have all the information we know
what guys average spin rates are and
what they were the last couple of starts
and so we have seen a couple guys you
know against us who their stuff has
picked up a couple hundred rpms which
makes you think you know maybe
there's something going on but i think
for the most part
uh you know these little as you call it
tsa checks coming off the field have
have done a pretty good job of managing
it so because i'll be honest just from
my again my end of the the the remote
control in the couch
the games are more watchable over the
last couple of months and i i don't know
if again from your perspective in the
batter's box that it's been uh more of a
level playing field that you've
literally seen a difference between
april may
half of june to half of june july and
the current month
justin
yeah i mean i think the the top tier
pitchers are still going to be the top
tier guys i don't think that um you know
it's really separating them that much i
think the biggest difference in
guys using stuff was was the lower end
bullpen guys who were now picking up and
pitching like the the top end guys which
you know obviously
you have an entire staff of guys with
dominant type stuff it makes the offense
pretty scarce and um when you're
watching baseball
and offense isn't happening you know it
can be
considered or deemed you know a boring
game
so i think uh you know now that
they're managing it and guys are kind of
coming back down to
you know where they're supposed to be at
uh there's a a little bit more offense
even though there was some irony the
other day and ken rosen's all saying
that the uh
the no hitters were gone and extinct and
obviously the guy from the diamondbacks
goes out that night that he said and
throws a no-hitter so i thought that was
pretty funny in his first career start
too
my god
he's still wet behind the ears that was
unbelievable that was right
he was actually with us in spring
training last year and uh he we had a
tick tock competition and he submitted a
pretty good tick tock
in our competition so it was it was kind
of cool to see him go out
well he's beefed up his resume a little
more since then you know um yeah so
you're in addition to being world series
champion two-time all-star you are now
the head of sports and wellness for
fresh and lean
what what's this uh tell me about
fresh and lean
justin yeah it's a
company that my wife and i courtney have
come across in our journey to you know
just eating clean eating healthy um
port introduced me to this diet this
last offseason called whole30
um it's basically an elimination
elimination diet and you eliminate all
the sugars and
carbs and and
dairy and
alcohol everything gets eliminated and
you basically just eat clean for a month
and uh the results i got from the
whole30 diet were
unbelievable i lost 16 pounds in 30 days
and
the first time in the last 10 years i
was able to get under 200 pounds which
was always my goal and i could never
accomplish it so um i'm now a huge
believer in in the whole 30 diet and i
got to team up with fresh and lean
and come up with a whole
line um between court and i think
there's 80 meals
lunches dinners and snacks that are
whole 30 approved uh that you can order
from fresh lean now and uh it's
basically an organic food delivery
service that
will get you more in a couple
couple days and then you pop it in the
microwave for two to three minutes
you're on the stove from five to seven
and you got a
pretty good
really good uh clean hot meal uh for
lunch or dinner well and i mean
no sugars are you i mean are you a sugar
guy i mean again i mean there's like gum
everywhere in your clubhouse i mean
i i you know yeah i mean how do you
you really got rid of sugar i couldn't
even imagine lasting a day
without that because it's in everything
it's in everything man
so i think the hardest part the hardest
part for sugar was desserts and uh soda
right and cutting out soda cannot
desserts other than that i think i'm
i'm pretty good um on the sugar side
all right well it sounds great and you
for more information go to
freshnlean.com and since you know you're
the only representative of fresh and
lean uh can you just let them know that
they didn't ask me to use the name
because that was the name of my rap
group in high school
um was it really yeah i was i was fresh
um
no i'm just kidding the dj was lean
and you you you had me going there
come on justin i know i don't know if
we've ever met like literally in person
but i mean i think we might know each
other and i'm yeah i'm i i don't think i
was in any rap group but just i heard
fresh i was gonna i was gonna ask you to
spit a couple bars
no so fresh and so late
mcfresh has been uh put away for quite
some time but uh congrats on this it's
great that you're you and your wife are
into it and it's done so well and let's
talk uh as you get closer to the
playoffs and be on justin i always
appreciate our chats always appreciate
it absolutely thanks for having me again
always at red turn two on both twitter
and instagram that is justin turner
world series champ
los angeles dodger third baseman
two-time all-star and the new head of
sports and wellness for fresh and lean
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here